[Music]
hello everyone I'm Jim Vidal
today I'll be doing the play like the
pros lecture so I'm actually gonna show
two games not to complete games but I'm
going to show a snippet of this Adams
game and then I'm gonna show a game by
Hari Krishna he was hired Tristan yeah
had him had a senior moment in my 30s
not good alright so these games were
both played at the Gibraltar Masters
which just concluded as I mentioned in
my previous lecture was won by Levon
Aronian but I didn't feel like showing
any of his games so I chose one game by
Michael Adams or one babes by Harry
Krishna two of my favorite players
actually and they both had victories in
the last round one was a fairly
straightforward victory one not so much
so I figured we'd start with this one
this was Adams against Neil's grand
Elias very very talented Swedish player
and the question is what do you do it's
black to move here opening was fairly
standard Sicilian with Bishop e5 check
Nikki likes these kind of things because
he likes to play kind of slowly
positionally sort of his style so if
you're black here what do you do what do
you consider any thoughts doesn't have
to be a genius move just anymore
Asics looks pretty normal to me it could
be he was worried about allowing b4 and
the knight has to run back but I don't
know then c4 can be a weakness I don't
know the a6 looks ok moves like Queen b6
look fine looks a little funny but
you're just trying to play rook 88
complete your developments Locke has
plenty of decent options unfortunately
he didn't find one he played this move
so the question is what's wrong
d5 is a very typical Sicilian move right
usually if you can get in d5 safely it
means that you're gonna equalize or even
get a better
that good things will happen to you but
it's one of those moves that can be a
little treacherous if you play d5 at the
wrong moment it can actually be a losing
or very bad move and this happens to be
one of those cases so what do you do if
you're white how do you take advantage
of this premature push
okay and then ah
[Music]
so sometimes d5 is wrong because you
simply win upon you just take upon but
other times it's just in this case black
is slightly less better developed than
white it doesn't look that way because
you know two rooks out three pieces out
but White's pieces are very are a little
bit more active and this knight in
particular is quite nasty so now if pawn
takes pawn there's a very easy
refutation
check must take with rook right that was
pretty simple now your upper rook should
be sufficient to win at the GM level one
would hope so black really can't take
this pawn you could push but then you're
just giving back your pawn at the very
least so black decided well I don't want
to give up my bishop I'll just slide
back and this idea actually makes a lot
of sense so white took black took white
took black took and it looks like this
is actually very clever if the Queen
takes maybe you play rook d8 and play
Knight d3 all of a sudden your pieces
are kind of coming in I don't know you
might get some good counter play I think
part of the idea also was after Queen
takes first of all pawn takes that pawn
just becomes a weakness after Queen
takes I think this might be his idea
actually trade to the endgame and this
end game I don't think it's gonna be so
easy to win this Knight is no longer
good I'm just gonna kick it away I all
know open the open file even though
you're up a pawn you're gonna have a lot
of difficulty winning this position and
I think that again grant delius's idea
maybe he just miscalculated it's very
possible and he definitely did because
he missed what Mickey could do but he
basically thought I don't want to get
tortured in a slow position that's what
Adams likes to do all the time so I want
he wanted to kind of solve his problems
a little too eagerly again I'm just
guessing maybe he just miscalculated
something but white actually has a very
very nasty move here nice little shoots
and Ruge that didn't solve it
whoops
so the idea now of course is that a pawn
takes Knight Queen G for check and it
mate
and here it looks like what have you
accomplished well it's one little thing
you just have a temple now and how do
you defend that f7 pawn not so easy
right if 96 this pawn hangs there's just
nothing so black played Queen e6 white
snag this pawn and that was up to pawns
you do own the open file still but in
general two pawns more than compensates
for an open file white just played here
and eventually won pretty simply two
pawns is just way too much so kind of a
brief example but the basic thing is
that when you're about think you're
about to solve all your problems
take a second glance that if you if you
lose five minutes and play it anyway
those five minutes aren't gonna cost you
too much but if you're wrong if you
allow an initiative if you allow some
tactics you could end up really
regretting this push even if he's
slightly worse after move like Queen b6
after a move like a six he'll take that
position any day over to playing d5 too
fast so kind of beware of situations
like this especially if your opponent's
pieces you find they're springing into
action even if you don't see the
knockout take a second look it often
means there's something there so in any
case I thought that was kind of an
instructive example so this one Hari
Krishna was black a very strong gem from
India against Mario move Z took one of
the their Gibraltar tends to get a lot
of very strong female players they offer
good conditions and things like this so
she's one of the ones playing 2540 quite
a nice GM herself so this game was
actually quite interesting because Hari
Krishna won in the end
spoiler alert but it was not an easy
road so I'm going to breeze through the
opening to make sure we have some time
this is kind of an interesting system
and one of the things I like about Hari
Krishna is that he tends to be fine
playing systems which are not that
common
he doesn't mind going off the beaten
track when he plays a lot of players
really stick to only main lines and
there's nothing wrong with that but he
tends to choose lines not that are bad
but that are sort of side lines which
are a little trickier and he gets kind
of more interesting positions sometimes
this way so he's a good player to follow
and I certainly failed at not talking
too much in opening this Oh Bishop g2
efore 92 this is one of the options by
the way of playing g3 Bishop d2 early
that you allow yourself your knight to
go here sometimes rather than if you
play a Knight f3 move order of course
there are drawbacks you're committed to
fianchetto a meta 3 does not but this is
kind of a setup which sometimes occurs
so this is the idea so what exactly is
black doing Matt I asked look at these
pawns
look at this Knight you're pinned what
is the purpose of this is he just a
crazy person or was there an idea yeah
so the idea is that if black plays d5
which i think is strategically a very
poor move then you don't play here right
away like an idiot what you play first I
really was close I was broke I apologize
and now Knight c5 comes and this square
looks pretty nice right the fact that
you have this pawn remember what I said
about weaknesses in earlier lectures
it's only a weakness if you can attack
it if you play knight Knight c5 Queen b6
there's no real way you're gonna attack
that night and you can see how this
close center really doesn't help play in
any case um why does an experienced gem
she's not gonna do that she played a 92
black played Bishop e6 so now it's
really obvious right it's like please
play d5 play d5 of course she's not
gonna budge him
she plays h3 I don't actually know about
the
three whether it's useful or not I think
she just wanted to keep pieces out she
wanted to keep some options open but
here Hari Krishna chose what I'd call a
risky move I thought that I mean taking
on d4 I think is maybe what computer
wanted but taking here you get the c5
square but what's the main drawback of a
move like this well the knight does go
to the center that's very true d5 this
night stays bad that's a good
observation but apart from this night
getting in what weakness do you have now
yes
so this pawn structure is not quite as
nice as with the pawns in the center so
it's kind of one of funny situations one
of those times where white actually does
not want to have that space advantage
the space advantage hurts you because
the pawn on d5 makes it so you can ever
attack anything it's kind of a funny
situation but it's actually fairly
common in any case I mean there's
nothing wrong with taking exactly like
this is kind of normal you have to live
with pawns like this when you play a
system like this just kind of the way it
goes but I wouldn't want to take so I
don't know I kind of like this waiting
move rook e8
because the idea is if white wants to
play a move like a four now it's
playable but I'd say it's a little risky
because now you take and then there's
diagonal action and I don't know this
looked double edge to me but higher
attrition has tried to be more concrete
he played this move but I believe he
underestimated or maybe he saw it and
simply wanted to make the game
complicated but Moseley took found a
really really nice continuation though
and it's the kind of move that players
miss all the time but one that you have
to keep in mind in this kind of
structure again notice how if this pawn
were on a more normal Square this would
never be an issue but because blacks
pawns like are like this I move like c5
can be really nasty because now you
can't defend your Center and with the
Queen on da defending this pawn a move
like this is not as effective you can
just take and probably win a pawn but
now that the queen is not guarding d6
this is a real problem so this was a
really really nice move by Musa ship I
think maybe objectively best was to play
with d5 here
kind of a tricky move but after takes
takes takes you get a position like this
probably it's more closer to a draw than
a win but it's kind of unpleasant
because you have to be pawns and white
as an extra pawn doesn't always mean
everything but I would say that it's
much harder for black to make a path
pawn and make the extra pawn count you
know so this is the drawback of playing
a system like this by the way that if
things liquidate a little bit sometimes
you're doubled pawns you can kind of
regret in a position that's completely
closed of course the doubled pawns are
I'd say close to meaningless because
there's no past pawn anyway right but he
wanted to complicate the game a bit more
and it makes sense and this you'll find
this happens that especially the last
round of a tournament it often means
that drawing doesn't really get you much
a win will get you some nice prize money
I don't know exactly how much he'd get
here with the wind but he basically had
to win so there are ways you can
complicate the game not get a lost
position but create some risk but I
think it was too much so he took on h3
she of course grabbed the D pawn they
exchanged Queen e6 and here she found a
very very nice move you got to be
careful you got to keep you want to keep
everything together your Knights look
kind of weird but they actually hold on
to your Center pretty well in general
you'd rather have them on these squares
but this pawn kind of annoys you
do you remember the speech at all about
opening up your King I'm just I'm just
curious that it's not related no I mean
it's it's a it's a type of move you got
to look at because once in a while like
this is just totally crushing but
something tells me here it's a little
too much so let's see what do I want to
take first of all probably I'll take
this guy also by the way I hate to oh oh
this is this is kind of embarrassing now
right so like I move like this right oh
man that that's this is why you got to
be careful with every pawn push I know
this belongs in my pawn secrets of pawns
lecture but I'm revealing a pawn secret
and in another lecture hopefully I don't
get arrested you got to be careful about
the weak squares when you push spawns
right so here I don't know it's a little
weird but but also I think I can
probably take this guy first right this
is simpler because now if you play e5
I'll happily go here right and this
would be you know you have a nice pawn
chain but this check is gonna that check
could cause a divorce that check yeah
you didn't know I was gonna bring
marriage into this all right so f4 be
careful now her move was really really
sweet here yes so bringing her rook into
the attack and putting pressure on this
pawn note how the Knights stay nice the
King stays more or less protected and
this is just a really nice move because
now for example if pawn takes pawn in
here first of all you don't have any
nastiness with this you also can't check
on d5 to defend the pawn but the rook
covers so you're gonna have to move your
knight somewhere and then I mean I take
here all the squares are covered perfect
peace harmony and needless to say you do
not want these pawns in your face
well I'm I'm guessing she found that
move when she played c5 because
otherwise this whole thing is actually
not as good now if she was really clever
she would have found it before she
played h3 but that's probably too far
that's even Karlsson I don't think would
see it that far in advance but after
Queens e8 if your idea is c5 which is a
really strong idea you kind of have to
see this because in this position I
think it's the only move that really
secures you anything otherwise your
center can fall apart but after okay
five and maybe she just saw it at the
last minute it's possible you know we're
all human beings but the key is just you
need to put pressure on the center while
also keeping your position solid that
means keeping these pawns defended it
means keeping your king safe and this is
really the only way to do it right so
you can do it by process of elimination
and also by looking at temple moves it
looks like a fancy move but really it's
a temple move you're attacking upon but
it's about controlling squares once you
see what squares you have to control
usually if there's a way to do it the
piece that has to do it will come to
mind you have to control both these
squares at once there's only one piece
that's gonna do it right and that's kind
of where this move comes from but it's a
very nice move regardless black takes
here oops but here we come to a major
decision do you take on e5 with the pawn
or with the rook and finally we come to
a decision which she actually did not
make correctly so I would divide this
choice into one move is more tactical
which move is that and the other is more
positional rook takes why is rook takes
more of a positional move nope although
true but not the reason so basically I'm
saying yes but you're wrong yes you have
these two monsters work takes preserves
these two pawns so they can try to roll
down black space which as you know is a
very common tactic if you play pawn
takes your forking the two pieces and
you're maybe getting an attack or
whatever else you're getting an
initiative but your Punk you don't have
the two ponds that are like
so your pawn structure technically is a
little worse than people at context so
it's the question of which which is more
important here hobby you think you
figure that up there you go it was a
trick question but I didn't trick anyone
here did it definitely don't do it I I
Bluff all the time usually
unintentionally meaning I blunder is
when I'm saying but don't trust me this
is all I'm saying maybe other players
you can trust don't trust me I'm gonna
I'm gonna lie I'd lie to you definitely
if there's anything to learn from all my
lectures I would lie to you the last
lecture the last lecture I blended a
room I mean it happens
he wouldn't get made it wouldn't but I
think that you're kind of overestimating
how many moves white gets in a row it
turns out wide only gets one move at a
time in this particular position so that
that attack is gonna be a little slower
than you're imagining to give you an
example pawn takes was actually played
yeah rook takes is actually just a
really good move you keep the two pawns
she probably thought that he was getting
some counter play against the pawns
maybe she miscalculated pawn takes but
for example if 97 the only thing I came
up with she was worried or rook would
get stuck but you can play for example
94 bring the Queen to the center rook f5
is always available if you need it f3
comes if you need to solidify this pawn
d5 can come if you need a temple move
it's just too solid these pawns are not
useful pawns roll in the center why I'm
not gonna say why it's completely
winning but one's much better so this
would have been a strong move but it's
easy to get lured by tactics especially
if you think they work her idea of
course was not to take the knight maybe
it was and she missed something but yeah
taking the net I think is just bad
because I take this rook I play roof d8
pinning you how quick exactly do you
think you're gonna do this you're a
little slow right yeah it's it's
important not to give yourself like I
mean when we're calculating we all kind
of have calculating fantasies and it's
very important not to give yourself too
many moves in a row that's one of the
common mistakes people think they get
way too much time
remember your opponent has moves if they
have useful moves they can probably stop
you from doing what you're doing
so Queen d8 and I'm not exactly sure
what she missed
she played rook b5 and black has a
really really nice move now maybe this
is the one she missed I don't know but
honestly even if I didn't see this move
I would Polly Tate with the rook so I'm
not exactly sure but nevertheless it's a
very nice move
so now your night is ready to come out
your rooks attacks so this is sometimes
what can happen the risk of playing the
tactical way sometimes you missed one
move and your whole advantage falls
apart so you have to be very careful you
have to make sure that the tactical way
is indeed working I would say that if
you're ever really short on time if
you're ever not sure if you see a way to
secure such a huge positional edge you
would need to be sure of your tactics to
not play it I doubt that there was huge
time pressure this early in the game you
never know there are some people who are
true addicts but I would say that this
was not the situation to go for the
tactics easy to say in retrospect when
I'm just looking at it but rook takes
Knight takes e4 Knight f3 so it looks
like White's gonna end up just up a pawn
here right but it's not so simple black
plays Knight back here somehow it went
from white having slightly more activity
in the center due to this weird Knight
to black actually having really annoying
pieces not to mention this pawn is gonna
look a little tender so what to do now
to trade or not to trade well you kind
of have to trade at some point because
your rooks hanging but do you take the
Queen or do you not take the Queen
I am here anything you said except that
you would not take so good job however
you need to move so route p6 I think is
a nice move but you have to see a little
far ahead here I'm gonna take and play
here oops but I still would play this
way and it's all about the pieces you
can make black very uncomfortable with a
certain piece you play a rook here and
now
you have two choices to attack the a6
because this is the piece I'm eyeing
right that piece looks really sad I'm no
psychologist but I'm pretty sure that
night not happy right so do you play
rook d6 or okay one so R okay one I
actually think it's a mistake because
now I play here and I'm actually
attacking two rooks didn't know Knight
be a could be an active move did you so
this is actually not so good but you
play this one and now I have to play an
IV eight except now you can move back
and I don't know the knight lens I'm b3
I'm not saying this is better for white
it might not be it's one of those
positions where probably this Knight
gets back in the game you know but you
are you have a lot for your pawn but
this was the moment where she had to
think activity she had to think okay
make sure I'm not worse probably it's
just a draw cuz probably you win this
pawn but the knight gets out is usually
the way these positions work again it's
that I have an experience thing I can
just tell you usually it's worth the
pawn but not worth more than the palm
when it's this reduced usually there's a
way to give away the pond and get this
dude out so something like this move you
know I don't know see tonight here but
now you can probably gang up on this
look see for I'm just giving an example
look here tonight has another problem I
guess I can go to c5 that would be bad
so I guess I have to be a little more
careful than I am which is not
surprising see so okay seven there
should be a way that real in this pun
almost always there's something so let's
see ah maybe you just start with rook c4
just go after this guy right away right
rook p7 so I was thinking this but now
you have b3 Oh No yeah probably a draw
this guy is really bad but I don't know
if you can win it but okay here you
probably wouldn't do that you'd probably
just come out like 97 we trade we shake
hands or something again I'm probably
making some errors but the basic idea is
that usually you can win that pond but
you gotta let the night out it's just
the way the world works according to me
so in the game though black took or
white took sorry but now the problem is
that this night is gonna head in and
then you have two nights to worry about
not just one so without being able to
put the knight on b8 it becomes a little
problematic so white did this and now
white has to be careful so you see how
quickly the game turned she went for the
more tactical line which at first looked
super promising right
she gets the two but you saw how quickly
things fizzled so be very careful about
these decisions so white played rook c7
again I think she had to actually stay
behind this pawn I don't think leaving
this pawn behind was a good decision she
wanted to stay on the seventh he could
kind of play that way but it turns out
to be rather tricky
he plays h6 keeping the net out 91 okay
one
so now she's gonna lose b2 again life
not so simple
but she finds a counter play a little
bit she wins this pawn but unfortunately
because this is weak now the e pawn has
to be given up so 94 rook beef 7 all
pretty logical
so how can white make counter play here
you can try 96 but I suspect you'd have
a problem with this guy now let me see
so for example see how I want to start
this
maybe he takes where do you go h3 or g1
okay now I want to go rookie
so pick your poison rook or Knight least
I'm hoping it's poison otherwise I'll be
embarrassed again which might happen
okay
gotcha no you g4 don't give up so soon
the problem is that you I can play a
rookie for now and take this so I don't
know probably too much right you mean
here no I mean you can it's just you're
probably gonna lose the upon whole song
yeah
keep in mind also you have to make sure
this pawn stays guarded right so the
reason she did this is because she wants
to make sure that she gets a rope on
that beep on cuz that beep on you'll
give it a couple moves and it lands on
b2 then you can resign so basically she
white plays King f3 with the idea that
now the King gets nice and active at
least and if Knight takes then she can
consider moving the Knight to f5 see
that so what is black dude this is the
real tricky phase because so far they
played more or less logical wounds she
checked she was sure she won f2f seven
black up the night actor but this phase
is immensely complicated in general rook
and Knight ending can get very nasty
they combine in unexpected ways good
so oftentimes you're kind of taking a
lesson from white whites activating
their King alright time for me to do
that
almost always I'd say in the endgame
mistakes that are made are either
pushing pawns too soon or not activating
the King 2 most common mistakes I see at
the amateur level especially but even in
even in master games so if you're in
doubt just activate your Kings own sin
of course this calculation behind it but
the idea is that once your King gets
roaming your opponent's life becomes a
lot harder so white played Chuck so
where's the King doing first of all
that's the one thing if you start
roaming you have to make sure you have a
place to go but where's the King headed
okay so let's run let's run but what now
yeah this king wants to be running this
way the problem is white didn't really
have a better thing to do because next
I'm just gonna take this pawn anyway
like I was thinking at first that maybe
I could have tried the problem is if you
go to 96 your knight just gets way too
far away and it's not gonna really end
too promising Lee so yeah this is too
far
so why tried this but here she found a
good move probably the only move
actually hmm very nice so black grabs a
pump
and this was the key moment
take some before is not a great move it
turns out
it's black smooth
also so the work was actually took in
the game
no this did not happen so what's the
idea if I play a king d3 yeah this
should do
I guess does this move though but now I
check and there's this right
you can't go here yeah yeah I'd say this
is one of the things that like Hari
Krishna is a very good positional player
but I think in his heart he's a
trickster he's very very tricky
tactically a lot of his games he wins
with kind of cool tricks or checkmates
and things like this so he's always kind
of on the lookout but ok what's the idea
if I play King f3 still legal right in
Missouri I don't know but how'd it do it
g6 is interesting so you're gonna play a
93 the problem is that you passed the
move to black so I can maybe play Knight
f3 check on you or something so probably
you can't play a waiting move just yet
93 so I guess there are two
possibilities there's King h5 or King h3
I don't know why I'm not listing this as
a legal move but I guess it's meat so
okay let's try King h5 life is hard huh
yeah Brooke h2 I run to g6 you're kind
of chasing me where I want to go so 95
so if 96 I have King d6 I assume that's
the ending of six and you're gonna meet
me what do I have but I think you can be
a little less fancy about it justice
wins cuz rook g4 is not even available
because you have checked maybe I have to
try this but I didn't think this worked
yeah I have check
ah ah
you can hide out on h8 if you want but
something tells me this is not going to
be a draw yeah I could even just
actually this is kind of embarrassing
but I can even just go here if not oh
why am I so proud of my son yeah you
could try a trick the last trick last
trick the problem is it's not much of a
trick because here you go here right but
I go back and then oh no it still works
yes trick BAM look at me
oh but this move will do it now because
you can't go here coz rook takes here
Knight takes and if back it's got to be
some win maybe you can just be real
embarrassing about of course you can
look I went I went a little faster than
intended I'm allowed to enjoy myself in
any case yeah this this Knight to g5 is
quite strong I think so I could play
rook c4 but I think you have something
here what do you have here actually
what to do not so simple I'm actually
very curious like because this position
for some reason because you know I play
I play Type R obviously prepared this
today I play I picked a bunch of moments
but it's always easy to miss for some
reason rook takes before escaped my
attention so I'm very curious if I'm
missing something more obvious here I
don't know what to tell ya so she
probably could have taken this pawn but
that's the thing is I'm guessing there
was time pressure also to be fair to the
guy what other choice does he have you
know she defended it well she did this I
thought rook g6 was actually a way to
draw but this is a hard move to play
also because you got to allow check and
play here and make sure you don't lose
any Knights but she played check which
was actually not the best so here
actually
he could have won with this move because
now you don't get to take the pawn at
this I did check if rook takes d4 I can
check here and take them in and if
Knight takes you can probably use your
imagination but King c5 I believe is
quite strong because now if 93 you can
even just take it and you don't quite
get enough so I don't know why you
didn't play King D 5 but again I'm
guessing that there was time pressure
involved it probably nerves and again
these kind of positions you can see how
tricky they are that position looks so
promising 17 yeah but I don't know what
it means 34 17 maybe it could have been
how long they took they could have had
twenty minutes and spent 17 seconds I
doubt it but it's pretty tricky but okay
she checked he went this way yeah and
then here I think she also played a
mistake she could have checked on d4 or
on e stone and this mistake by the way I
feel like this is the kind of mistake
you can learn from because I think this
one you can actually just figure out
regardless of how little time you have
there's a way to distinguish between 97
and 94 now could be she just
miscalculated that's always a
possibility you know you always have to
take direct calculation into account
maybe after 97 she didn't want to allow
kingi five because ninety seven halves
rg6 check maybe but I know for sure
which one of the two I would play and
for a very very simple reason I should
say
how do you choose between East 7 and d4
without calculating a lot of lines and
say you have 15 seconds left
yeah you're more centralized you're
closer to both sides almost always if
you're in doubt choose that I'm telling
you the amount of times it's wrong is so
rare compared to how many times it's
right it's just not even close so I'm
not saying you know if you have tons of
time to just blitz out 94 that's a
terrible way to play you know chess is a
concrete game there are lots of times
you have to play moves like 97 but I
would say if you don't have the time and
you're not sure
keep the neg towards the center yeah so
this was actually a moment she could
have taken this pawn maybe but now at
least I have this move just kidding
check so this is the important feature
right so tonight here but now you take
and this is pretty simple so there he
did have a trick but yeah 1994 check I
think would have been better so the King
has to go here because that's the thing
if you go here now I have rook g6 check
takes and the problem now is that you
don't have this pawn I guess I have to
watch out for an IG 4 check but then
king f4 King f3 and it's even possible
that I move like King f3 is kind of
clever now keeping this Knight at bay
again very very complicated position but
King g5 would probably be played to
avoid rook g6 but you can see how this
is at least still unclear you still have
this pawn covered you might win it this
pawn is a little bit better guarded so
when the game this was played but now
the King gets a nice safe haven Knight
g4 check this pawn is loose
she takes the pawn but the problem now
is the 927 right so what do you think
will cause white problems now
Mia but more specifically the beep on
hello forgot about me didn't you
I I meant to do my beep on voice but I
haven't done it no one so yeah this is
already quite tricky and by quite tricky
I mean probably just losing so white
tries night up five maybe white had a
better defense somewhere but honestly
this is already very difficult probably
white had to try something like they
defy to try to get the night again try
to get this night back you know but I
think that it's just too tricky because
I can play check for instance and then
rook moves so I don't know exactly where
I was gonna move to g2 but that would be
unfortunate about f2 but this beep on is
kind of nasty huh so I don't know you
got to stop this guy somehow but it's
not such a simple task and in the case
yeah I mean there's also an IG for by
the way because notice how if you go
closer I have this check if you go
closer here I take but it is just one
pawn so you have to be a little careful
also there's Knight f6 93 moves h5 is in
the air still but yeah
yeah it's a little unfortunate
well yeah honestly to play this position
with no time like no one's gonna play
this perfectly but she played a knight
f5 and then rook c2 was rather strong
and the purpose of course is that now if
Knight see to what do you think you guys
do who cares that your ropes hanging
you're gonna get a queen so if I go
behind
and then rook
that's a hole that's a hole rook so it's
a little bit too much so she played
behind but it was basically the same
thing she tried taking this pawn but so
he messed around a little bit but I
think he was gaining time but you still
got a pawn to stop it looks trivial but
I've seen situations where you have a
knight but it's so far away it ends up
not being able to participate so just to
make sure your technique is good what do
you do
stop that pawn notice how king up five
runs into ninety three check so I go
here closer right
now what
you want to make sure that your opponent
can't play g6g zone on you right
what piece can be improved mm-hm yeah
King H for probably okay I like that e
to check though because now you make
sure the King can't go here because you
have 94 now the King and this was then
guess now 96 checkers could me can't be
stopped so fairly trivial but again the
key is just make sure this pawn can't
move bring your knight in you need to be
up a rook for being up a rook to matter
if the Knights here you're probably not
gonna win so you need to make sure your
piece gets in but once all the pieces
are in it should be fairly trivial so
again a pretty messy game obviously my
analysis of it needed a little work but
the main thing was that the position
changed quite a bit like out of the
opening she found a lot of powerful
moves so his goal was just to stay in
the game right
but once the tide turned she had to be
very very careful she had to make sure
she found that kind of play got the
knight passive because once you know
what once he got to that endgame where
his pieces were really good it was tough
to defend even if she had draws in that
position to draw that in an actual game
with the pressure on you and having no
time against the 2750 player not an easy
task
so it would it would have been difficult
for anyone to draw once he got all that
activity but one of the things to notice
was that you know he kind of flowed with
the position when the position was
against him he's trying to find his only
defensive tries which he did once the
position was around even he kind of
outmaneuvered her once he got the ending
her advantage he wasn't winning he
wasn't winning for most of it but he
kind of found his chances he found what
he had to do so chess I mean it's nice
to play that one game where you just
kind of knock your opponent out kind of
like Adams did but usually you need your
opponent's help remember how his
opponent basically blundered out of the
opening so if you don't have your
opponent's help if your opponent plays
strongly then often it's a mess you have
to kind of just roll with it but usually
the person who kind of collapses
last or is not gonna end up on the good
end so really he just kind of outlasted
her and eventually was able to
[Music]